[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une chasse nous avons lancé dans
l'aisne nous avions jusqu'ici une chasse
sur hirson une chasse aux en plaine en
forêt et nous avons voulu lancer dans
l'aisne une chasse aux canards notamment
ils devront trouver là un prieta
terriens qui s'est intéressé cette
formule
nous pouvons prendre ici à fourdrain
une vingtaine de chasseurs la journée
avec un prix de journée bien sûr qu'elle
est terminée par le prix y était
quel prix de la journée le prix de la
journée sera de 250 francs
pardon pour tous ces coups de feu à vos
oreilles yannick jadot mauvais souvenir
oui c'est pas que des souvenirs c'est le
présent vous savez quand je suis dans ma
picardie dans l'aisne le samedi matin
dimanche matin ça tire à 150 mètres de
la maison donc effectivement vous pouvez
pas sortir donc vous ne pouvez pas avoir
accès à la nature et puis c'est vrai que
là ça ressemble à ça ressemble à un
massacre en fait et puis c'est quand on
était gamins avec mes parents on fait
toujours mais on est vraiment dans la
forêt la forêt magnifique et quand quand
vous voyez une harde avec insert superbe
les biches vous voyez les chevreuils
temps en temps on peut voir un renard ou
des sangliers c1 c'est fabuleux enfin
j'veux dire c'est pour moi ça reste à
chaque fois un m'émerveille mans et
imaginer qu'en fait un cerf aussi
majestueux deviennent au fond une cible
qu'on va abattre et qu'on va tuer pour
le plaisir parce qu'y compris la chasse
à courre c'est même pas pour manger la
viande puisque il ya ce qu'on appelle la
curée et finalement vous la donner au
chien il ya quelque chose qui me va pas
donc effectivement jeu
il faut il faut que tout le monde puisse
accéder à la nature il faut que les
chasse cruelle s'arrête
et que et qu'on respecte les animaux
parce que respecter les animaux c'est
aussi c'est aussi se respecte est en
fait donc le refus ou la détestation de
la chasse qui est inscrit dans votre
programme et non j'ai pas inscrit dans
mon programme la détestation de la
chasse le refuge as j'ai inscrit mon
programme le fait que la chasse sera
interdite et le week end et pendant les
vacances scolaires pour que toutes les
familles et y compris les chasseurs
évidemment sans leurs fusils puissent
profiter de la nature parce qu'on a
besoin de la nature et qu'elle est
magnifique mais ça c'est ancré depuis
l'enfance ça c'est ancré depuis
l'enfance parce que c'est vrai que
c'est pas enfin c'est la nature les
animaux ça fait partie du beau et j'ai
toujours du mal à consac comprendre
qu'on puisse vouloir tuer le bo voilà il
ya quelque chose avec qui qui qui qui
m'interroge toujours
[Musique]